the u.s. and Cuba have had one of the
world's strangest relationships think of
it a Caribbean island nation of just 11
million people locked in a 50-year
standoff with the superpower but now
with the re-establishment of ties and
easing of a trade embargo can these once
bitter enemies become good neighbors so
here's how we got to the current
situation the u.s. severed relations
with Cuba in 1961 after its leader Fidel
Castro allied Cuba with the Soviet Union
at the height of the Cold War when the
u.s. failed to remove Castro with the
Bay of Pigs invasion and imposed a trade
embargo and that's how things stood for
about a half a century but then
relations between the two sides formally
resumed in July 2015 today I can
announce that the United States has
agreed to formally re-establish
diplomatic relations with the Republic
of Cuba the diplomatic thaw was made
possible by swap of imprisoned spies and
Cuba's release of a jailed American
contractor as part of the deal with the
u.s. Cuba's government promised to
expand some freedoms and it released 53
political prisoners then afterwards it
stepped up arrests of dissidents on the
other side Barack Obama used executive
authority to make it easier for US
citizens to travel to Cuba and in May
2015 the u.s. removed Cuba from its list
of state sponsors of terrorism the u.s.
terror watch lists the US military base
Gitmo is not part of the deal now here's
the argument Obama says he wants the US
trade embargo on Cuba fully lifted but
that would require an act of Congress
closer us ties could also help
marginalize left-leaning Cuban allies
like Venezuela but opponents of
normalization say Obama has only thrown
a lifeline to a dying dictatorship the
bottom line without support from
Congress
Obama's changes could be undone by the
next president